[Aplausos]
[Música]
imagina un país con menos población que
el barrio de manhattan pero que tiene
reservas de petróleo y de gas natural un
país que está rodeado de las
petromonarquías más ricas del mundo
[Música]
en este país estamos hablando exacto de
bahrein un país tan pequeño que a duras
penas lo vemos en el mapa a estas
alturas seguro que todos pensáis que la
vida es maravillosa en este lugar dinero
para todos economía próspera y
crecimiento sin igual verdad pues lo
cierto es que las cosas no van
precisamente bien por aquí
para inés degradada a la categoría
basura mientras la represión política
continúa sin cesar habéis oído bien la
deuda de bahrein está considerada como
'bono basura' en el mercado
internacional es decir que hay dudas muy
serias de que su economía sea lo
suficientemente sólida como para
devolver sus préstamos y lo cierto es
que las cosas en bahrein son de todo
menos tranquilas si seguís visual
política desde hace tiempo ya sabéis que
dentro del mundo islámico hay dos
grandes grupos por un lado están los
sunitas y por el otro los chiítas y se
llevan a matar literalmente
[Música]
si queréis entender mejor las
diferencias entre unos y otros en la
descripción os dejo un vídeo donde lo
explicamos a fondo lo cierto es que
arabia saudita es el país sunita por
antonomasia y la república de irán es
algo así como la disneylandia del islam
chiita y por eso estos dos países llevan
inmersos en una guerra fría durante
décadas
[Música]
pues bien en bahrein tienen una
situación cuanto menos curiosa en este
caso la mayoría de la población es
chiíta pero la casa real que los
gobierna es sunita y eso explica que los
reyes de bahrein hayan hecho de la
opresión un auténtico arte pero vale
hasta aquí todo normal lo que ahora os
estaréis preguntando es por qué decimos
que bahrein puede convertirse en el país
más rico del mundo pues por noticias
como ésta
[Música]
para in descubre el yacimiento
petrolífero más grande del país desde
hablamos de zumo de dinosaurio a
cascoporro chorros y chorros de petróleo
de repente bahrein podría tener más
petróleo que rusia pero con una
centésima parte de su población vamos
que hay muy poquita gente para repartir
el dinero así que ahora la pregunta es
es esto suficiente para que paren se
convierta en el país más rico del mundo
porque teniendo tanto petróleo se sigue
considerando que su deuda es 'bono
basura' y está pasando en este país hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
una jaula de oro veréis si algún día
alguno de vosotros quiere convertirse en
dictador de su país tenéis dos modos
para hacerlo la vía más tradicional es
la clásica mano dura de toda la vida
problema que es y reprime demasiado te
arriesgas a un levantamiento popular
os lo hemos dicho mil veces en visual
político ser dictador es una profesión
de riesgo pero hay otra alternativa
mucho más sostenible la de las manos
llenas
es decir cubre de dinero a tus
ciudadanos si no tienen que preocuparse
por buscar trabajo tampoco tendrán que
preocuparse por la política suena bien
verdad
pues la familia al jalifa que es la
dinastía que reina en bahrein mezcla
estos dos métodos para que os hagáis una
idea el primer ministro que es el tío
del rey tiene el récord mundial de
longevidad en el cargo
[Música]
llevan el poder desde el año 1971 sin
embargo como consiguió una dinastía de
confesión sunita aguantar tanto tiempo
en el poder con una población chiíta
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
como decíamos antes tenemos la clásica y
tradicional mano dura de toda la vida
protestas contra el gobierno pues te
mandan a la cárcel pena de muerte o
simplemente te echan del país y no
creáis que hablamos de un caso aislado
es algo que ocurre prácticamente todas
las semanas
[Música]
para retirar la nacionalidad a 115
personas por acusaciones de terrorismo
más de 700 personas en bahrein han visto
revocada su ciudadanía desde 2012
[Aplausos]
y si ya sé lo que me vais a decir
fonseca que en otros países democráticos
también retiran la ciudadanía a los
delincuentes por supuesto pero como
siempre la diferencia está en las
medidas en reinounido los casos se
cuentan por decenas en bahrein estamos
hablando de cientos y si pensabais que
las cosas están evolucionando a mejor
estáis muy pero que muy equivocados en
2011 durante las primaveras árabes el
pueblo chiíta salió a las calles a pedir
más democracia
la respuesta no se hizo esperar arabia
saudi empezó a mandar tropas a bahréin
por la calzada del rey fahd uno de los
puentes más grandes del mundo con la
ayuda de emiratos árabes se reprimieron
violentamente las protestas a día de hoy
1 de cada 500 personas en bahrein es un
preso político y entre ellos están los
líderes de los grupos chiítas que llevan
varios años entre rejas no sólo eso
desde 2011
bahréin ha aprobado leyes para facilitar
los trámites de pérdida de ciudadanía y
creerme perder la ciudadanía bahreiní es
mucho peor de lo que parece a simple
vista
[Música]
retirar la ciudadanía supone
convertirlas en personas apátridas sin
derechos
los condenados entregan su documento de
identidad su licencia de conducir no
pueden tener una casa un coche un
teléfono una cuenta bancaria no pueden
casarse ni registrar legalmente un hijo
los que se exilian no podrán volver y
los que optan por quedarse no podrán
salir del país en definitiva que los que
se oponen al gobierno se convierten en
ciudadanos de segunda y creerme es una
auténtica desgracia porque mis queridos
amigos de visual político ser un
ciudadano de primera en bahrein es toda
una bendición y aquí es cuando entra a
la política de las manos llenas lo que
podríamos llamar el contrato social
bahreiní
básicamente si te olvidas de la política
vives del cuento buscas trabajo tienes
un hueco en la administración pública y
tranquilo que nadie te va a pedir que
sudes demasiado tienes que ir al
supermercado los alimentos están
subvencionados echar gasolina al coche
precios por los suelos y qué pasa si
quieres trabajar en la empresa privada
pues no te preocupes el gobierno
garantiza cuotas de trabajadores que
tienen que ser locales ningún inmigrante
te quitará el puesto de trabajo
y esta es la mejor parte de todo porque
estas cuotas están pensadas para que
estos bahreiníes de primera puedan
trabajar en los puestos más agradables
por ejemplo en los bancos de bahrein el
50% de los trabajadores tienen que ser
locales en las tiendas de ropa un 30%
pero en la construcción sólo se exige un
5% por qué pues porque para poner
ladrillos es mejor contratar a
inmigrantes para que os hagáis una idea
el 55 por ciento de la población de este
país son extranjeros y son los que
realmente trabajan en el país
y aquí tengo que hacer un paréntesis
porque veréis esto de tener más
población inmigrante que local es algo
muy típico de la zona para que os hagáis
una idea qatar tiene casi un 75% de
extranjeros sin embargo bahrein es uno
de los pocos países de la zona que han
abolido la llamada kafala y que es la
caf a la os preguntaréis pues es algo
así como la esclavitud moderna
el sistema kafala hace que los
trabajadores extranjeros estén ligados a
un ciudadano nacional que es su
patrocinador y que es el que decide
sobre cuestiones como permitir si puede
cambiar de trabajo o incluso si puede
abandonar el país o no pues bien
bahréin lo tiene abolido así que bueno
las cosas como son un aplauso para ellos
sin embargo y pese a todo lo que ahora
estaréis preguntando es este sistema
donde casi nadie trabaja es
económicamente sostenible pues la
respuesta es rotunda
[Música]
[Aplausos]
120 dólares vivir sin trabajar es muy
caro y si en bahrein se lo pueden
permitir es simple y llanamente por una
cosa petróleo el zumo de dinosaurio
supone más de un 60 por ciento de las
exportaciones del país y un 75 por
ciento de los ingresos del estado
[Música]
y dónde está el problema os preguntaréis
pues que para cubrir todos estos gastos
el gobierno necesita que el barril de
crudo cotiza a 120 dólares si vale menos
no tienen suficiente beneficio y diréis
120 dólares es mucho o es poco pues
veréis en su máximo histórico en julio
de 2008 el petróleo llegó a cotizar a
147 dólares pero como bien sabéis en el
año 2014 los precios del petróleo
empezaron a caer en enero de 2016
llegarán a los 26 dólares y eso explica
cosas como esta
[Música]
standard and poor's reduce el rating de
bahrein ave positivo así que ante el
bajo precio de crudo y la falta de
ingresos el estado ha recurrido al
endeudamiento el resultado habla por sí
solo la deuda pública ha pasado del 7 al
70% en sólo 10 años y aunque los precios
del crudo estén volviendo a subir no
parece probable que volvamos a ver los
120 dólares en mucho tiempo en bahrein
ya han tenido que quitar las
subvenciones a la carne y eso es sólo el
principio
para in lanzará el iba a finales de 2018
según el ministro de finanzas habéis
oído bien en bahrein no hay impuestos de
la renta y hasta ahora ni siquiera
tenían un impuesto sobre el valor
añadido pero la situación es desesperada
y no les queda otra que empezar no a
subir sino simplemente a crear impuestos
que antes no existían y os preguntaréis
pero todo esto que puede suponer para
bahrein pensadlo bien todo el sistema se
basa en lo siguiente el pueblo chiíta
acepta a unos déspota sunitas a cambio
de vivir sin dar un palo al agua así que
si la economía falla la política también
sólo un milagro podría salvar a la
dinastía de los al jalifa y ese milagro
es este
[Música]
petróleo a manos llenas bahrein produce
200 mil barriles de crudo diarios
realmente no son muchos a nivel global
pero es una barbaridad dado el tamaño
del país
como ya os he dicho bahréin ha
descubierto este año un enorme
yacimiento de petróleo y podrían estar
empezando a bombear zumo de dinosaurio
en sólo cinco años según los más
optimistas esto duplicaría la producción
y podría acabar con el déficit el
problema que no todo el petróleo cuesta
lo mismo el petróleo saudí por ejemplo
es muy barato de extraer porque puedes
porque pinchas en la arena y ponchó ros
de zumo de dinosaurio en escocia por
ejemplo es mucho más caro por qué pues
porque está debajo del agua y necesitas
plataformas petrolíferas
[Música]
sin embargo este nuevo yacimiento de
bahrein tiene todos los ingredientes
para ser carísimo primero está debajo
del agua y además es lo que se llama
petróleo de esquisto es decir que está
incrustado en una roca que hay que
romper primero en otras palabras
necesitan fracking y sabéis que el
fracking es de todo menos barato
[Música]
fijaos en esta gráfica aquí podéis ver
el coste de producción de un barril de
petróleo en distintos países no podemos
hacernos una idea de lo que costaría el
fracking en bahrein pero si podemos ver
lo que cuesta en eeuu si os fijáis
veréis que el barril de esquisto es
sustancialmente más caro de producir que
el barril normal para que bahrein pueda
hacer un mínimo beneficio el petróleo
tiene que estar por encima de los 60
dólares pero como en bahrein necesitan
unos beneficios aún mayores para pagar
sus gastos ni siquiera teniendo este
yacimiento se van a salvar así que ahora
os preguntaréis que puede salvar a
bahrein de la ruina pues muy fácil lo
mismo que en todos los países de la zona
diversificación es decir tener otras
cosas y no sean petróleo cosas como esta
[Música]
donde les abre su fábrica del futuro en
bahrein invirtiendo 90 millones de
dólares pero claro si realmente quieres
atraer a empresas de todos los sectores
necesitas algo más que yacimientos de
petróleo
necesitas un sistema político serio
donde los impuestos son claros las
reglas son claras y el gobierno no puede
meter en la cárcel a quien le dé la gana
lo hemos visto en muchísimos otros
vídeos dubai y en general
emiratos árabes unidos- ya empezaron
hace décadas a modernizar sus sistemas
arabia saudita está siguiendo el mismo
camino y es cuestión de tiempo que
bahrein siga el mismo ejemplo sin
embargo aquí está la pregunta creéis que
los ciudadanos aceptarán un gobierno tan
autoritario ahora que les van a obligar
a pagar impuestos ya trabajar o tal vez
las reformas económicas tendrán que ir
acompañadas de reformas políticas
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
y por supuesto no olvidéis visitar
nuestra página de patrón donde tendréis
acceso a contenido exclusivo por cierto
suscribiros también a este canal
si no lo habéis hecho ya para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones y si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]